but we have we have actually we actually
have a very very serious story to open
with
i'm i'm reticent to even get in this
this is dark stuff all right
so i hope you guys are ready check this
out tonight uh bill clinton speaking
tonight right
i believe so yeah so i've seen a bunch
of tweets talking about bill clinton
speaking tonight at the dnc
and this story came out at the same time
exclusive this is from the daily mail
would you mind giving it a crack bill
clinton leans back and smiles while
receiving a neck massage for an
from an epstein victim so i'm not i'm
i'm not gonna
look this is just a photo and this is
the news that's coming out right now
bill clinton who is in i guess 26 flight
logs with epstein
a photo was just released of one of
their trips
and one of epstein's victims is seen
giving bill clinton a massage
i'm not going to pretend like this image
comes out of some
dark nefarious you know uh island
excursion
because what we what what i believe this
is they say that this was when they were
going on their their world tour or
whatever
the aids relief thing to africa but it
would what it does show
is that bill clinton was literally
connected to the things that epstein was
doing and this
what's really scary to me about this
photo is that
it just looks like a woman giving a dude
a massage yeah and then once you learn
the context
you're like whoa a former president of
the united states
receiving a massage from a trafficking
victim
of one of the most notorious i just call
them nasty guys man
like truly evil and despicable uh people
i bring this up
not necessarily to go into you know the
epstein stuff but for
you know obviously we we are a bit
because we're still waiting to see what
happens with max well not stuff but
let's talk about the democratic
convention
the authoritarianism and i guess just to
and we can kind of opine on this because
you were just mentioning
the democrats have become authoritarian
so i guess
i would ask you as you know you've been
you were a democrat sjw whatever yeah i
was a lifelong democrat
i did vote for my first republican in
2018
i voted for wow i voted for ted cruz
because
much like trump in this case i felt he
was the most liberal person running
and i felt beto o'rourke was again an
identitarian
authoritarian and i couldn't vote for
someone like that he didn't support free
speech
you know he was pushing my old belief
system my old ideology which is not
liberalism social justice ideology is
not liberalism no of course not it's
authoritarian
i don't know marxism it's it's born from
marxism it has roots in marxism but the
best way i've learned to describe it for
people is that
if you think of marxism as marxism said
the best way to look at the world
essentially is as a competition for
power
between no as a competition for wealth
between class groups
so this new kind of marxism this
identity marxism
says the best way to look at the world
is there's a competition for power
between identity groups so it sounds
like racism
yeah but they want to do the same thing
they want to redistribute power the way
that marxist of old wanted to
redistribute wealth
right right right um but it's just an
evolved
not as in better but it's evolved as in
a mutated kind of marxism
i want to i wanted to highlight this
story because the dude's speaking at the
dnc i mean that's the
gist of the story there's not much to it
we know that you know clinton was flying
on this plane but i think there's
something
inherently wrong with the democratic
party at this point not not to say that
republicans are clean
right you know but the dnc right now is
this weird mishmash of people who are of
seemingly no conscience right i i think
they've become unmoored from
principles yeah did they ever i
when was the last time you felt they had
principles this is a
tough question for me tim because
looking back i can't tell how much i've
changed and
that skews my perception now and i often
ask myself this
like did the democratic party is it that
the democratic party changed and then i
changed alongside it or
is it that i changed and i can't see
that it was always like this
the democratic party definitely changed
okay but people like bill clinton have
been doing really awful things for a
long time and getting away with it
so i think you know where we go from
here that's really interesting with your
history and this
is that there's always been this kind of
dark element
in politics in general you know bill
clinton's been accused
he's paid out settlements i guess to
people like what was it
juanita brought her he paid her a
settlement or was it i can't remember if
he paid or sell them or not because i
know
probably not because she keeps talking
yeah you want to look that up yeah i'm
going to check it out right now because
uh he the clinton's paid out somebody
i'm pretty sure but you know so bill
clinton's been a kind of a bad dude for
a long time
but when you look at you know policy
wise i think what we actually see when
you realize
there's there's a lot of people like to
look back and romanticize the left left
me the democrats left me i think that's
not true
i think there was a period where the
democrats
as a party that just panders were
pandering to a large group of people
that were ideologically aligned
and was relatively close to where the
republicans were
as the progressives started to move into
the democratic party
they kept trying to pander and now
they're spread super thin desperately
trying to pander to everybody
that says to me you know how is it that
you can have someone like bill clinton
speaking at this event
when seemingly by their own ideology he
is a patriarchal
misogynist and all these really awful
things you know they can screech about
brett kavanaugh
because some woman vaguely remembers an
incident where he like threw a
threw around the bed i can't even
remember when it went or how it happened
but bill clinton who's got real accusers
and all this really awful stuff is
totally a-okay
i i look at the the party today they're
entertaining this guy
so did the party really change i kind of
don't think so
i think they're just pandering to a
different group of people
i think there might be something to that
i mean my mind immediately goes too
that's a
that's a philosophical question because
i think that's what happens when you put
ideology or party or tribe or something
or anything above principles
yeah because if you don't have universal
principles that you apply across the
board even when it's
uh hurts your ideology or hurts your
party
then you don't really stand for anything
you'll go with whichever the way the
wind blows
right i remember a bunch of videos have
come out
showing you know bernie sanders and
chuck schumer pelosi all these democrats
you know 12 or so years ago talking
about the need for border security and
immigration reform
there's like some article i pulled up
recently it's from 2012
where the democrats were talking about
pushing a payroll tax cut and how it was
great a great idea for everybody huge
win for obama
and today it's like trump is trying to
gut social security
so i see that and i'm like man it looks
like they've changed
right the democrats have changed and
then i'm kind of like no
maybe they didn't care about that back
then either yeah maybe we look back and
we're like see that made sense but this
doesn't and it's like wait a minute
they were they've always just been
saying whatever they think we want to
hear
i'm sure i'm sure it's relatively true
for a lot of these you know old
established republicans but many of them
are running fleeing and joining the
democrats as never trumpers
they're like the one group of people i
guess that have left the right to join
the left
yeah they have wealth you know yeah well
you're making me think of something i
said you earlier which is that
this is pretty naive but it wasn't until
recently that
uh my podcast partner uh carter he he
told me
i guess i always thought if you want to
get ahead in politics or anything you're
just
you behave like a good person and you
behave you put on the best version of
yourself
and you are the best version of yourself
and you will win
friends and you will move ahead and
the better you are you know kind of you
rise to the top and he sort of pointed
out to me no
what happens is that uh if you think
about it probably a lot of
people who have enough money or power to
help you
they'll want to have something dirty on
you to hold over you to make sure they
can control you
so maybe it's the worst people who rise
to the top in politics
it is it's so you know you know what i
was thinking though with trump
i mean you find yourself as a what do
you call it
reluctant deplorable yeah i mean yeah
uh there i i think there's a lot of
people who have proudly switched
and there are a lot of people have been
like i guess i'll switch right
so i
i don't know i forgot how what i was
going for on this one
that's okay but uh i don't know do you
want to just
take it well being a reluctant well
well somebody in the comments on the
post you did today was saying
um oh i guess this is enough to forgive
trump's war you're trying to defend
trump's words or forgive his words
no i'm not i have no interest in
defending trump's
warts or whatever as long as he doesn't
have a wart called
racist sexist marxist authoritarianism
and he doesn't
so i remember now okay hey don't get mad
at me those listening i work like 16
hours a day every day yeah i'm probably
going
to i saw you work today you have a crazy
schedule my brain's probably going to
explode okay so what i was going to say
is
i started trailing off into you being a
trump reporter all stuff but what i was
going to say
in in response to what you had just said
trump to me feels like the youtuber
of politics do you like that i
love it but you do you know what i mean
by that yeah like
youtubers came out and they were very
much
authentic personalities it was like all
of a sudden these vlogs started to
emerge of people just filming themselves
with their phone
and people loved watching it because it
was real
and everything we got from the media and
from politicians and our whole lives has
always been plastic
yeah i can't stand more than anything
it's like something will happen in the
world oil spill
and you you know what they're gonna say
you know exactly what they're gonna say
before they say before they say it
it was a terrible accident we're so
sorry everybody and you're like shut up
you're lying
somebody you know cut a corner you're
trying to save money just we
we get it it's bs trump comes out and
he's got no filter
and people go finally he's like the
internet's generation
this authentic personality and a lot of
people don't like it
but to be fair he has absolutely chilled
out over the past year or so i mean this
year he's been very
calm and and and much better tempered i
would say
you said that earlier and i i hadn't
considered that before but i think you
might be right
for me that's big you know i i've often
said
of of the policy things i didn't like
you know missile strike in syria there's
a lot of foreign policy stuff he's he's
up to drone strikes
he's actually reversed course he started
doing a bunch of really
good things and i'm sitting here going
like he's actually
i used to say you know trump's bad he's
not that bad because like the media
would
really twist it now i'm like trump's not
that bad he's actually kind of okay
you know kind of okay it's kind of okay
yeah and and that's very triggering
i think i think i'm actually getting to
you know very very soon we'll see how it
plays out and it's the media's fault for
sure
i'm probably going to get to the point
where i'm like trump trump's pretty cool
you know
because i'm i'm looking at him and i i
had a self-reflective moment because
somebody commented in one of our shows
saying
you often complain about trump's
demeanor and and his professionalism
what would you prefer and so i said i
was like that's a good question i
thought about it and i'm like
you know he hasn't really had any of
those moments where he was
you know like well actually earlier this
year he had the uh the scarborough thing
you know where he was talking about
scarborough's intern yeah
msnbc i think i missed that but isn't he
always doing that
but that's that's kind of the stuff i
don't like okay yeah but he's definitely
improved he watches press conferences
and he's just like
he's like thank you for your question
thank you very much and i was like wow
he was he was the guy who was like you
are fake news you are fake you know
see i kind of i had moved far enough
away from the legacy media or at least
realizing what liars they are
that i sort of i got to a place by the
time he told jim acosta
what fake news he was i was like okay
this is one thing he's doing that i like
i don't know look yeah i i
got to go to the white house for his big
social media summit thing oh yeah
he's a funny guy he's he's an excellent
entertainer
and and that's that's kind of the point
i'm making because when i'm there and
i'm watching this
you know for me it's basically i look at
a politician and i'm like you can be
you can be all smiles you everyone loved
obama on the left because he was a
celebrity i i'm not falling for that
game again trump can can stand up there
and he can make jokes and make me laugh
i want to hear some tangibles you know
then he started talking about things i
liked you know he crossed into the dmz
and that's that you know the the north
north korea south korea thing is is very
relevant to my family
because i have my my literally i'm
korean and i have family
that goes back to north korea i'll never
get to go visit those places
so seeing trump do that with no security
walking into north korea
i was i was just like i'm sitting in my
chair i'm clapping i'm like that is
awesome he had no security people these
people on the left they don't get it
they could have snatched him up they
could have killed him
and what would we do go to war or
something trump did that i respect that
it may be symbolic but whatever i see i
see now
you know i've known this for a while
it's like the democrats in the
establishment right now
the media it's all this facade it's all
make-believe
totally it's the fake news they're
desperately trying to hold the mask over
their face
and trump is has been ripping it off
he's been pulling off he's like you said
he's the youtuber of politicians
i've heard the wrestler analogy before
too he's a wrestler
and he he kind of really isn't but he
just sort of points out that it
is all a performance it always was
and he's so over the top that you you
suddenly realize you're in a wrestling
ring because there's a guy with a big
foam finger
waving it yeah that's trump you're like
oh this is all
i've been to so many of his rallies you
know when he was running the first time
i
actually covered a bunch of his rallies
went down met people and i saw the
escalation of violence
these you know was really crazy for me
and this probably contributed
to i you know a lot of people say tim
pool is like the slowest
world's slowest red pill or whatever
because oh they say that stuff about me
or they used to don't worry about that
no no i i don't care it's like listen
you know i do my research all day every
day
my opinions and my policy ideas and the
things i i support don't change because
people are nice or mean to me
yeah but it does there's an influence on
you know people being nice and mean
contribute to the fact that some people
will never have access to certain
information
if the left won't allow a conversation
you'll never hear what they have to say
so i remember for me there was a big
moment when i
filmed this is this is this is crazy i
filmed a guy
whack a trump support in the back of
that with a bag with a bag of something
and he's bleeding i film it i'm watching
these people just beat the crap out of
these trump supporters
i worked for this company fusion and
they were super excited about it
got we got a request for fox news and
they said tim go go on fox news
the employees the company got mad at me
after the fact for doing it
and they were like why would you go on
fox news and i was like they told me to
i don't know like i i'm a journalist i
guess i covered it and a news outlet
asked me to speak about it
but when i started telling them they
were like who are these people that were
attacking trump supporters and i was
like oh those bernie supporters
and they were like no it wasn't no it it
was it was bernie supporters
and some of some of these people were
like how do you know they were bernie
supporters
one of the guys was wearing a bernie
shirt oh my gosh well
just one guy with a bunny shirt somebody
was having a bernie flag yeah
and they're like no they're lying
they're not what do you mean i don't
care
like i at the time i was actually for
bernie
you know yeah they didn't want to hear
it they didn't want to hear it
that was probably was that like around
2015 maybe
i i'm pretty sure it was it was the san
i think san jose rally there's a very
famous video it's got like a million
something hits okay
this is a weird small world moment
because can i tell you something yeah
so when i first started going down like
the path
that i'm on leaving the social justice
left people always ask well what
happened
it's not some magic thing where i just
wake up the next day
there wasn't some you know one book or
one video or one thing
but there were several things and one of
the first things that happened was that
i went down a rabbit hole of videos
of trump supporters being attacked by
people who were supposedly on my side by
supposed liberals and progressives and
they made me
cry and one was that san jose video and
i had no idea you filmed it was it was
the guy with the yellow pole yes
and he was bloody he's bleeding and then
i asked him what happened i don't know a
guy hit me
you know i saw i saw him walking out of
the rally and the crowd started
screaming and throwing stuff
and i just knew i'm like i've seen this
i know what happens next so i started
filming
and the dude like i don't i don't know
if he didn't know or he's just very
brave
it was him and like another guy he just
kept walking minding our business he
didn't say anything didn't do anything
he was bleeding bleeding yeah pretty bad
and
i was just like i gotta i gotta i gotta
ask this guy what happened you know why
why is he's like i don't know i said i
came out i was yelling you know trump
trump trump and then all of a sudden
these people start attacking me
there were some guys in anaheim they it
was an older guy and two
younger guys and they were trump
supporters this was a little bit later
on
they told me that they initially
supported bernie sanders because of his
trade policy he opposed the tpp he
opposed nafta
but when hillary clinton won they said
you know the next best choice is donald
trump
they got attacked and i watch the same
thing this is at anaheim just across the
street from like disneyland or whatever
i don't know disney world whichever one
it is
and they chased these guys like a mile
stole their hats were hitting them
shoving them
and i watched all that stuff happen none
of these
these these lefties these bernie people
wanted to hear it they would they would
get so
triggered the moment i would say the
violence needs to stop
even bernie sanders himself had to yell
stop the violence
yeah but they still you know they put it
on trump when it's his supporters
getting attacked
yeah and that blew my mind because as
someone who was
deeply you know ensconced in my own sjw
echo chamber
i had just been fed this narrative that
the violence was that trump supporters
were violent
and that their rallies were and i
believed all this stuff without seeing
evidence of it i just believed it
so that youtube rabbit hall i went down
then i doubt i could
i doubt that would happen today i bet
they've changed the algorithm to such a
degree that i couldn't find video after
video i don't even remember
why i clicked on the first one but after
there was video after video there was
the girl that was egged
yeah the one that was san jose that was
that was also and
uh and that just it shook me because it
was it was visual evidence
of the opposite narrative and i didn't
know any of that had been happening
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you